[Music]
1.6 trillion dollars in student loan
debt everyone's talking about it
most people are affected by it some
don't even realize they're affected by
it's a problem
the average student that graduates
graduates with $35,000 in debt a lot of
you are facing student loan debt
problems a lot of you have little
children and you're thinking about the
cost of education and what you're facing
as you're going into that this is a big
deal in America
joining me Rachel Cruz best-selling
author Anthony O'Neill best-selling
author I'm Dave Ramsey of the Dave
Ramsey show we've been pounded to the
point that when you're talking to high
school students getting ready to go to
college they almost think it's
permission to play you have to go into
debt to get to be on the stage and it's
the biggest myth of ma Dave and it's not
just but there are young people's even
with their parents our parents and the
students do not even believe it is
possible to go to college one it was in
debt free and it be honest I didn't know
I didn't know it was possible to go into
college without racking up debt and I
took out loans just to go to college and
not really to pay for my college
expenses but Dave dissipate from my
lifestyle because the education wasn't
out there and I just I'm tired of it and
I just I'm here to help educate and
bring hope to young people to that to
know that you can go to college
debt-free okay so that's our statement
you can go to college debt-free now how
do you do it what's the big things you
have to do well here's a number one
thing dave is that you know one thing is
we got to start educating our kids and
one of my good friends kevin says that
where our students are making kit or
doing a kid's approach to an adult
decision you know they're going off to
colleges saying you know what hey this
is my dream school I want to go here all
my friends would hear this is good I'm
gonna go this it's a beautiful campus
beautiful campus but you know what a lot
of students get upset at me because I
say you know what your dream school
should not be that dream school your
dream school should be a school that you
can afford to pay cash and if you can't
your dream becomes a nightmare yes sir
well I was gonna say to you have to go
into the mindset of this topic to say
absolutely no matter what there's no way
I'm going into debt so you take debt
completely out of the picture then
suddenly other options come in going to
a school you can afford scholarships and
grants like this is free money I always
tell high school students take this
approach where this is your part-time
job and even if it's a $200 scholarship
it feels like a drop in the bucket
compared to your tuition but take thirty
minutes
fill out the form write the essay and if
you get that scholarship or grant you
need two hundred dollars in 30 minutes
okay I'm like that's like the best part
time job ever so make it that and get
that free money the thing about the
college choice is in the equation
scholarships matter the grants matter
those kinds of things matter but college
choices the
biggest math on the equation because you
can go from sixty thousand dollars a
year to two thousand dollars a year
absolutely in this discussion from a you
know a community college that in some
states is free or is two thousand bucks
a year all the way up to a muckety-muck
prestige sixty grand and it's okay if
you go to any of them as long as you can
pay for it but if you're trying to pay
cash and you don't have any money you
can get the education on the lower end
of that spectrum in an in-state school
and a community college and the other
thing is you've been talking a lot about
trade schools there's nothing there's no
shame and especially if you're in stuff
like technology or if you want to go
into a trade with your hands and welders
make more than a lot of social workers
with a master's degree they do that and
you know what one thing Dave I'm
teaching our young people is you gotta
identify your major make sure that this
major is profitable
once you identify you know what I want
to be a hairstylist so I want to be a
carpenter you don't have to go to a
four-year university you can go to a
trade school and learn that particular
trade but then six months spent about a
verse five to seven thousand dollars for
that particular trade school if possible
then you can get graduate and go
straight into the field making anywhere
from thirty to sixty thousand dollars a
year in income additional mechanics
making 80 rounds and so you know you
could go do that and then pay for your
four-year if you want to do that be well
yeah no shame in either's that's called
working your way through school I'm
working while you're expose a good thing
right
yes sir I recommend going to it what a
college student is something that racing
rth and even you teach this Dave work no
more than 20 hours a week because what
studies are showing that if they are
working while they're in college they
have some system ownership and when they
have ownership they can focus in their
classrooms better they don't get better
grades because now they have sweat
equity in a game and don't just go get
any job I mean you want to do the math
and say okay what's gonna pay like is
waiting tables and getting great tips
best is it is there something on campus
that they could actually put some money
towards your tuition like bistro teach
about it and think about it and it's
amazing even just getting you know if
you're a girl a nanny and job in the
city that you're in and work for a
family I mean like it there's so many
options and ways to make money and so do
it and again it's hard it's it's so much
easier to sign your name to a student
loan and to sign your name on that
dotted line it's hard to go to the
school you don't want to go to it's hard
to apply for those scholarships and
grants it's hard to
while you're in school it's hard to live
a lifestyle of a college student when
all of your friends are like you know
spending all this money but man those
short-term sacrifices for long-term gain
is so worth it yeah that way the 32 year
old version of you doesn't hate the 20
year old version yes we're having to
live like a college student once you're
out of college right and you know I
talked to the Dean of a business college
about 20 years ago and I've seen this
come up time and time again they had
done a study at a major state university
that showed that the amount of student
loans at that time being taken out was
the equivalent to the increase in
lifestyle
meaning the apartment that they rented
living off-campus they got a car they
did all these they spent money socially
and those kinds of things in the gap
that they were coming out with was not
tuition related it was increase in
college lifestyle so you know the
dreaded thing that you really are not
supposed to say out loud is you can live
at home you you really can't Dave cuz I
mean even studies are showing that if a
local in state university will be about
eight to ten thousand dollars a year so
if you stay home and eat at home you can
really graduate from an in-state college
for about forty thousand dollars that
saves you a lot of money on top large
here you can make delivery peach so
while you living at home easy that's it
uber do something never done so America
has done a horrible job the culture has
done a horrible job of selling you guys
on the fact that a student requires a
student loan and Anthony's got a new
book coming out that shows you step by
step by step exactly the things we've
been talking about on how to avoid that
the book covers that the free degree but
we talked about this you know you know
Paris it is overwhelming understanding
you have a lot coming before you with
this College process coming up but you
know what I wrote this book because I
want to help you get your kid into
college 100% debt-free so we literally
start to process from seventh grade
through 12th grade on what you need to
be doing in every year up into that
process and one thing I love about a to
Dave in this book we even teach parents
how to really master the AC T and SAT if
they can really focus and prep for that
and get some high scores this is a
difference between getting a partial
scholarship to a full-ride and we talked
about that and really how to be
successful in this book it's a step by
step clear path talking about the
principles that we just outlined and
it's only 1999 for me this is what's
known as a deal so you can get it at
Dave Ramsey comm you can get it Anthony
O'Neill comm you can get it anywhere a
great book is sold so be sure and check
it out because this you know really that
we have to treat the problem not the
symptom yes the student loan debt is the
symptom the problem is people didn't
know how to get an education without
debt and this is the vaccine so that I
don't know I'm really proud of you this
is a great book Oh
gonna be a big seller so don't miss out
I don't know how the free degree number
Anthony OD O'Neal that's it baby get
after